also if the UN is really so deeply
concerned with all this climate change
and all these human rights well they
should probably relocate closer to some
of the source of their problems again
the People's Republic of China would be
a great choice unfortunately the UN is
here to stay under Biden he he values
the global Community far more than we
the American people this is America last
on steroids tomorrow he'll speak to the
UN for the third time as president but
he has never managed to visit East
Palestine Ohio he you know he just can't
seem to find the time here with reaction
Fox News contributor Charlie hurt along
with host Tommy lahren fear uh fearless
and that of course on outkick uh Tommy
let let me start with you 34% of Voters
think Biden only 34% think he'd complete
a second term of reelected 72% of
Americans believe he's not physically
fit enough to be president obviously
people are also referring to his
horrific cognitive state
um now it's obvious James Carville even
pushing harder than last week and last
week it was Joe Scarboro Axel Rod
Carville um van Jones uh David Ignatius
Moren Dow I mean how many more liberals
have to abandon this
guy so Sean I've been saying it for
months I don't think that Joe Biden is
going to be the Democrat nominee in 2024
that's why we spend so much time talking
about his age and his cognitive ability
which is important to discuss of course
but we need to be doing what you just
did and laying out the failures of the
Biden administration because I think we
all know that it's not just Joe doing
that there's somebody pulling the
strings and those strings are going to
be pulled whoever the Democrat nominee
is so we have to focus on the policies
we have to focus on what they're doing
to our country what they're doing to our
border security our national security
our economy our children in schools we
have to focus on that because we can get
rid of Biden we can and plug and play
KLA Harris Michelle Obama or Gavin a
Nome but they're all going to implement
those same policies maybe worse so let's
talk about Joe not being able to
complete ascendant but let's also talk
about the Democrat policies that are
absolutely destroying this nation
Republicans got to focus on that
otherwise the next nominee that the
Democrats come up with they could beat
our nominee that's scary okay so Charlie
I've been saying that dominoes is
starting to fall Morin dowed maybe she
was the canary in the coal mine with her
article in the New York Times last week
David Ignatius but also van Jones AEL
Rod um James carille James Carville
comes out even harder uh this weekend
against Joe Biden then you had Joey
Scarboro liberal Joe to the mix okay
there's another one uh then you look at
Nancy Pelosi's comments not exactly the
most supportive of either Biden and very
very very tepid you know support of
kamla Harris well I mean vice president
doesn't do very much and well Joe likes
her so I guess it's she's the right
choice for that reason reason man what a
what a ringing endorsement that
was talk about damning with faint praise
that was probably the greatest clip of
the year uh and a real snapshot of where
we are and of course Tommy's exactly
right uh you know we do need to focus on
uh the policy uh situation because the
you know these policies that Joe Biden
has embraced are are going to destroy
the country uh we have an invasion at
the border obviously uh the Biden
Administration it's not that they don't
care about it it's that they are
encouraging it and they want it and I
think the Democrats want it the problem
is their voters don't want it which is a
plus for for those of us who want to
save the country uh because I think a
lot of Democrats would be open to the
idea of going with somebody like like
Donald Trump or or anybody else other
than the what what you know they see
right now on on the TV screens the real
problem for Democrats right now though
is the window is starting to close for
them in terms of getting rid of Joe
Biden replacing him with somebody else
and uh why don't you explain that
Charlie go into more detail on that cuz
this would you're right there so so
calendar is very different than in a
matter of months yeah so in a matter of
months we're going to start looking
we're going to be looking at a situation
where Democrats are not going to be able
to put somebody else on the ballot uh if
Joe Biden insists for the next two or
three months that he's still GNA run and
it's gonna become an absolute
catastrophe for them if they then try to
decide something after the fact and of
course the power of the incumbency for
especially on the Democratic side
because of their super delegates is
almost insurmountable and and we've seen
it with RFK JR we've seen it with other
uh Democrats who would like to to take
uh Joe Biden out it's going to be a real
problem for them and it winds up being a
problem for the whole party because if
they wind up with a gutshot nominee who
can't make it then uh then then it
lights out for them which is probably
good for the the country yeah Tommy you
know look at this how is it that Iran is
getting 6 billion from Biden and the
Biden Administration is pressuring other
countries to release sanction funds like
Iraq for example so they're getting more
money they're the number one state
sponsor of Terror we just heard in the
last two weeks they're getting closer
and closer to having not one but as many
is 10 nuclear weapons why would you ever
facilitate that listen I want every
American American home I do but you know
$6 billion and then however many more
billions that he's pushing and
pressuring other countries to give Iran
no that's a bad deal by any measure so
why did he do it and why isn't there any
criticism well yeah with this you're
just yeah you're just putting a price
tag on a future American hostages which
is the problem that's why we don't
negotiate with terrorists that's why we
don't pay for ransom payments for
hostages uh we should have never done
that how you justify giving $6 billion
or unfreezing six billion to Iran with
really no strings attached I'm not sure
but let's also keep in mind there's a
lot of evil in the world that doesn't
like the United States of America
doesn't like our way of life and
unfortunately Sean we have opened our
Southern border and said hey world that
doesn't like us come on in we're not
going to check you you're not we're not
going to document you we're not going to
vet you we'll get you a hotel room a bus
ticket a plane ticket we'll let you do
whatever you please so the American
people they might see things like Iran
and and giving money to Iran and that
might seem really abstract to them but
what should not be abstract is the fact
that you have countries all over the
world coming through our wide open
border 10 million plus to give some
perspective to that my home state of
South Dakota is less than a million
that's over 10 South Dakotas we've LED
in and there's no end in sight there's
evil in the world but there's evil
coming through our Southern border as
well and we're not doing anything about
it that's a great point and Charlie you
know look every single issue that I can
name here if we're looking at our
borders the price of energy uh Law and
Order Safety and Security um foreign
policy maybe maybe the better way to put
it is tell me one thing one policy is
implemented that has made our lives
better in what one way are we better off
than we were you know three years
ago there is not one single area that
you can point to and really honestly
this is the Democrat agenda this is what
the Democrat Party has become over the
last
five or six years and uh you know and
again the good thing is that Democrat
voters don't want it obviously uh you've
got a very powerful leadership in the
Democrat Party that is forcing the
voters to go along with this nonsense
but uh it's a tremendous opportunity for
republicans and conservatives to reach
out to these voters and appeal to them
the way Donald Trump did in 2016 and the
way Donald Trump is going to do again in
2024 by appealing to these voters who
aren't Democrat voters who aren't down
with this nonsense and they want to
salvage their country and then we got on
top of it Tommy the bribery and money
laundering Scandal allegations that are
hanging over the bidens um we'll get
into more detail in the next segment
however this you know for all these
idiots on television there's no evidence
at all whatsoever how do you ignore the
plethora of evidence I've gone over it
so many times I won't repeat myself
here yeah that's only going to work to a
point though and I think the Democrats
understand that and that's why you're
seeing a shift here and that's why
you're seeing a lot of high-profile
Democrats and Democrat pundits even
pundits who pretend they aren't
Democrats starting to turn on the Biden
family make no mistake Sean they have
played this game for a while but they
know that the clock is running and they
know that Biden cannot be their guy so I
wouldn't be surprise if you see more
media pundits talking more about the
Biden family crime scandals they don't
want this guy they got to figure out how
to get rid of him so I think the
pressure is going to be on the Heat's
going to be turned up just sit back and
watch all right so Charlie Tommy's very
clear she's been saying for a while she
doesn't think Biden's going to be the
nominee uh I think you vacillated a
little where do you stand now today I
keep vacillating it every week I come up
with a different answer to this uh you
know I do think it's it's it's a very
it's a very difficult thing to to
replace a sitting president uh
especially with the Democrat Party the
way they have a strangle hold on their
power but you know who knows anymore I
mean Joe B I'm surprised every time Joe
Biden makes it to the end of a sentence
yeah I think you're both right uh anyway
appreciate it Charlie thank you Tommy
good to see you thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else